Today for our experts
in emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with doctor Barbara
Fredrickson on positive emotion.
So doctor Fredrickson is a distinguished
professor of psychology and director of
the positive emotions and psychophysiology
lab at the University of North
Carolina.
She's a leading scholar studying positive
emotions and human flourishing and her
research on positive emotions
and lifestyle change is
funded by the u s national
institutes of health.
Dr Fredrickson has published more than
100 peer reviewed articles and book
chapters and with the publication of
positivity in 2009 and love 2.0 and 2013
she's written about her research
for general audiences as well.
Doctor Frederickson's contributions have
been recognized with numerous honors,
including the American
psychological associations,
Templeton prize and positive psychology,
and the society of experimental
psychology, his career trajectory award.
So I now turn to a very special experts
in emotion interview together with Dr
Barbara Fredrickson from the University
of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
So welcome Barb. Thank you so
much for speaking with us today.
It'd be here.
I thought what might be a fun way to kick
this off is by asking you a little bit
about what first got you
interested in emotion.
Yeah. Um, that's a great question.
When I started in graduate school,
there was really hardly
any work on emotions.
And ironically,
I,
I looked back at the first project
that I was involved in as a first year
student in college and it was somebody
doing in their senior thesis on emotions.
And I remember thinking, what are
emotions? How could, you know,
it was just that confusing to me.
And even as I was part of the very
first cohort of the NIH motion postdoc
program that,
um,
Richard Lazarus and Paul
Ekman put together at the
time and we had a year long
seminar on emotions.
And I think I was still halfway through
that thinking and what are we talking
about? You know, you kind
of had this sense, you know,
there's something important here,
but there was so little science
on it beyond face expressions,
um,
and a little bit of stress and coping.
So there really wasn't a fleshed
out of view of it. And you know,
that actually might have a lot to do with
the sort of stoic upbringing I had as
a family when the, nobody talked
about emotions. So, you know,
maybe I was coming at it very much from
the outsider's perspective, but um,
it's,
I,
I very much only came to understand
emotions from an academic angle.
And then I feel like I became
more fully human after,
after understanding more about emotions.
I didn't come from it
being fully human first.
And so by studying emotions you
become actualized in some way, right?
You've been doing, you know, I feel
like that's been my own personal.
Uh Huh.
So what I'd like to ask you a little bit
is about the really groundbreaking work
you've done in this area, especially
on positive emotions. So, I mean,
you're known widely for this pioneering
work and really delineating the
functional significance
of positive emotions.
You've published numerous articles and
you have several major books, you know,
love 2.0 and positivity.
And in particular,
what I wanted to talk with you about
today is your theory, you know,
the broaden and build
theory of positive emotions.
And I wonder if you could just say a
little bit more of sort of what are the
central principles behind this model?
Right. Um, the theory
first emerged from a,
a puzzle and intellectual puzzle of um,
trying to understand
how emotions involved.
And at the time when I got on the scene,
the main story about how emotions evolved
all hinged on the idea of specific
action tendencies that um, you know, uh,
kind of a fight or flight response and
emotions get you to do what's going to
save your skin in that moment.
And the kinds of things that had been
identified for the positive emotions
really were not specific
and often not actions.
So the, this sort of, um,
keystone concept that was our ability
or wealthy of understanding why emotions
involved just didn't fit at
all for the positive emotions.
And so when I was doing my postdoc
with Bob Levenson at UC Berkeley,
I started working on an
idea that he had had,
which he had written about casually in
a chapter before then. And I thought,
that's interesting.
I want to study that thing.
And his prediction was that well,
maybe positive emotions don't have their
own physiological signature or really
kind of a weight thing that they're
trying to do to the body or yes as you to
do, but maybe undo, um, negative emotions.
And so that's where I started with,
um,
with Bob in Bob's lab working on tests
of this undoing effect of positive
emotions.
I presented it at a major
emotions conference a couple
of years later and got a
lot of heat for saying that undoing
was the function of positive emotions.
And that kind of sent me
back to the drawing board to
read everything I could on
evolutionary perspectives, how to
make a proper evolutionary argument.
And I decided in the end that undoing
is not a function of positive emotions.
Undoing is a byproduct of one
direct function, which are really,
it comes in two phases.
Um, broaden and bill,
which happened on very different
timescales from each other.
Thing is what positive
emotions do in the moment.
They literally changed the way
your brain works along with you.
Taking more for the nation in
your peripheral vision expands.
Um, you're more creative. You connect, uh,
connect the dots to see the
bigger picture. And that's a,
a momentary cognitive change that occurs
while you're experiencing a positive
emotion. Now the other part of the theory
is the, so what, why does that matter?
How could this save your skin? Um,
and the key is that it
doesn't save your skin.
And the same way that negative emotions
might have led to a quick and decisive
action that would get you away from
a Predator, a positive emotion, um,
that broaden mindset,
um,
experienced frequently
allows your, um, you,
you're, you're, uh,
resources to accumulate and compound
and puts you on a positive trajectory of
growth.
So the key is the reason positive emotions
we're adaptive for our ancestors is
that by repeated experiences
of positive emotions,
we built up more social support, more, um,
resilience, better environmental
knowledge, better physical health.
That's where most of our
work is going these days.
And that you basically
become a more resourceful,
a better version of yourself in a way
that allows you to address future threats
and future challenges.
So the benefit of positive emotions
isn't in the moment that you experienced
them.
The benefit of them is having them as
a steady diet overtime so that you can
grow and become a more resilient,
resourceful person over time. So,
um,
broaden and build as a
process isn't one thing.
There's broadening that happens in
the moment that happens over time.
Um,
but uh,
together it kind of forms this
upward spiral that puts people on a,
on a positive trajectory of growth.
So what do you see as some of
the most central, you know,
empirical findings that have flowed
from this model? You know, I,
I,
I think we've,
in my lab we've done some interesting
studies on how positive emotions broaden
awareness,
but my favorite studies on broadening
awareness come from other people's labs
securely.
Like the work that Adam Anderson
has done where he's shown that,
um,
uh,
at very early stages of encoding people
are seeing more of the peripheral vision
has expanded.
And that's happening at a,
it's not something that
people report on later.
It's really happening at an
intake level that people,
when they're feeling good,
it's like they can't help but take
in more of the contextual surrounding
inflammation. And it's like, um,
it's like the door first of perception
are opened up and people taken theirs.
They're sponges for contextual and I
like how his lamb has also shown that um,
that more open visual perception
leads to more verbal creativity.
So going [inaudible] you see a connection
between different kinds of Broadman
and I've also collaborated with uh,
a kinesiologist and we've
looked at how emotion is
conveyed in body movements and we find
that there's broadening in the torso to
wow them with positive peoples also is
expand in ways that reflect the way their
mind is expanded and their visions of
their social relationships are expanded.
So um,
this broadened awareness or this
expansive way of being in the world is
something that comes through in
comportment and as embodied as well.
So those are some of the things,
things that I think are exciting on the
broadening side, on the building side,
I have to say the thing that I'm most
excited about right now is working on
changes in gene expression
in the immune system.
And we're doing a large scale study where
we're teaching people different skills
for a self generating positive emotions
and drawing blood before and after.
And then, uh, you know,
as long term follow up to see if we can
see chain ges and gene expression person
that track there, um, efforts to, um,
experience more positive
emotion and David for life.
It's fascinating.
I'm really excited to see where it goes.
Yeah, that's um, we've got very,
we've got some cross sectional
data that are very suggestive.
The tune on data are coming in soon.
Wow.
So one thing I always wonder,
I mean I love your model.
It's so beautiful and elegant and
having come from a discrete emotions
perspective, you know, myself, I,
I wonder to what extent you think this
model applies equivalently across states
that ranged from, you know, pride,
very self focused to gratitude,
very other focused or just reward
related feelings of enthusiasm and joy.
Do we know this at this point?
You know, we really don't know
this, that this by, um, uh,
we
and the,
the data are murky in my own studies.
We measure,
I mean I come from a discrete
emotions per se, the two,
and to measure people's self reports
of about 10 different discrete,
positive emotions.
And so far we find no distinctions
between them that are interventions,
which are specifically around kindness,
love and compassion.
They raise all the positive
emotions. Yup. Yup. Said pride,
even interest.
I mean that could mean that people's
self reports are just completely not fine
tuned enough to pick things up or it could
mean that people co experience these,
that they, they are positive
emotions are um, uh,
experienced as in,
in very overlapping in a
blended capacities. Um,
it could be that the way
people conceptualize them.
And I'll also, you know,
currently very influenced by Lisa Feldman,
Barrett pissed and then close to views
on how conceptualization matters.
Especially now that I'm offering a new
conceptualization of love and how people
seem to react to that when they say,
oh, I never thought about love that way.
And then they start experiencing it
a little bit differently. So, um,
it's not like, uh, um,
I don't think the kinds of data
that I've collected can, um,
actually say anything about
whether emotions are discreet or,
or not in terms of the way that debate
has been going on in terms of are there
discreet brain circuits.
Um,
discreteness doesn't always seem
to be honored in people's, um, uh,
self reports of the experience. And, um,
actually I sat down with Lisa Feldman
Barrett some some time ago and she said,
yeah, I was thinking about how
my work might relate to yours.
And she and I both kind of scratched
our heads and said they don't,
uh, neither one contradicts the other. Um,
so I think that's a great way to push
the field further is to really try to
understand where the boundaries between
those two and where does it matter and
where doesn't it matter?
One thing you alluded to in your response
that I wanted to ask you more about
that. I think so interesting as this
work you've done on intervention.
So really conducting these important,
you know,
translational approaches that look at
how we can cultivate positive emotion.
And I know you've done this among Indian,
those individuals even
suffering from severe mental
disorders like schizophrenia.
And so I wondered if you could say a
little bit more about the promise of this
as a potential,
you know,
intervention towards a building
and cultivating positivity. Right?
You don't want them. What's
interesting about it is that I, um,
I never thought I was doing
translational research or um,
develop the intervention.
It's just that the,
the side of the shape of
the bill hypothesis in the
broaden and build theory,
you can only test it if you look at,
well,
what happens if someone's
daily Diet increases over time?
How do they change over time?
And started test that got
me into a zone that, um,
looks like interventions
kicked up some interventions,
most certainly. Um, and we've
worked particularly with the,
the actually, when I first started
trying to test this part of the theory,
I had a number of failed interventions.
Hmm.
And then I realized I didn't
need to recreate the wheel
and build one on my own.
I came across this ancient technique
of meditation called loving kindness
meditation and realize,
you know,
my a big light bulb went off and I
thought I could use that test my theory.
So I wasn't really doing
research on meditation.
I was doing research on
emotions using meditation. Um,
but it certainly points out the,
the power of mind any as a way to
learn how to regulate one's emotions.
Um,
one of my colleagues here,
David Penn works on schizophrenia and
he heard me give a talk and saw that one
of our findings with our
normal subjects was, um,
that it's a learning,
loving kindness meditation helps
people anticipate or saver.
It's your positive events, which is, as
you know from an cranes were very much,
um,
at issue with schizophrenia and the,
especially the negative
symptoms of schizophrenia.
So we ran a number of groups where we
taught the same exact class that we have
hot too,
um,
healthy community members to community
dwelling schizophrenia with negative
symptoms.
And one of the most surprising things
is that these people were selected for
their negative symptoms, which means
they, they don't feel like, um,
they're not very motivated, that
don't want to be social. They're not,
they don't really talk about emotions.
Um, we almost had perfect attendance.
Wow. Each thing in and of itself
is that they kept coming past,
really liked learning
this new skill. And, um,
we found that on self reports there,
um,
negative symptomatology was improved.
Uh,
so it seems to be holding some promise
to kind of wake up the positive emotion
system, kind of take it off
the floor and raise it. Um,
and I think that could be useful in a
number of different clinical disorders.
I'm starting to collaborate with another
clinician where we'll look at the
effects of, uh, of loving kindness
meditation on social anxiety. So,
um, you know, as a social psychologist,
I do all the clinical work
in collaboration with, um,
people who are better trained for
dealing with diverse populations.
But I'm really excited to see those
applications come, you know, come on into
a test.
I mean,
it's amazing research and it's very
timely and much needed in the fact that
you're saying you're getting these
results with some of, you know,
when we think of psychiatric disorders,
the most severe and chronic
of them all schizophrenia.
I mean that's just so promising
and it makes me wonder, you know,
to what extent we can think about this
as a potential trans diagnostic type of
intervention, you know, to optimize mental
health more broadly across populations.
I know you're looking at
social anxiety disorder, um,
and so I wonder to what extent you think
we might be cultivating some critical
ingredients here therapeutically that we
can apply broadly? Right. Well, you know,
my,
Hi,
I'm take from the theory is that
positive emotions help us become better
versions of ourselves.
I'm mostly testing it with
healthy adults and um,
you know, that goes trans
diagnosis, trans diagnoses.
And so I don't think that would be any
different when you go into the clinical
domain since aspect of,
um,
dysregulation is so prominent across so
many different diagnoses that I think
that this is,
this is one that holds particular promise.
So having talked a bit about just
how you got started in emotion,
the really foundational work you've
done in positive emotion from you know,
this basic science per second aspect
of building one of the most, you know,
integral models we had to date and then
now looking at intervention research.
I wonder as you think about the path
that you've come through this far,
where do you think you see the future
of the field headed from this point
forward?
Yeah,
I think that it's going to be
more and more critical for, um,
emotion researchers.
And this is happening already,
but to work in team science with chemists
and a genetic guest experts and uh,
imaging expert.
I mean,
and see how far we can
understand the physical and um,
community effects of emotions.
I think that's, um, you know,
I'm originally trained as an experimental
social psychologist and our kind of
bread and butter studies are small
laboratory studies, one time tasks.
And I think that we're ready
to take that out to two larger,
bigger, bigger timescales,
deeper into the body. And, um,
we can't do that. Um, as individual labs,
this needs to be done as
kind of a big team science.
So I see that as something that we
should all be heading towards as at least
part of what we do. I mean,
I think there's, they'll
still always be a place for,
um, one time laboratory studies,
you know, to, to test ideas out,
but to,
to take it to a larger scale courses
depends on funding and things like that.
But, um, I think that's going to be a
really important funding priority too.
And then related,
I mean,
when you have students come to you asking
me for advice who are thinking about
embarking in this field,
what do you typically tell them?
You know, I think that, um, you,
everybody needs to find a part of the
fields that they're absolutely passionate
about because, um, I mean,
being an academic is, is, uh,
a tough job. And the payoffs
in terms of, you know,
when you get publications are
good news is few and far between.
So you need to be fueled
by your own passion.
And there are tons of great
questions out there. And, um,
just find the one that you
want to work on and dig it.
And don't worry if it
doesn't pay off right away.
There are a lot of people who
have very slow career starts.
I will always be one of that. Um,
some, you know, sometimes that just,
it just takes a while to get it
going. Well, thank you so much
for speaking with us today. It's been
wonderful. Okay, thanks. Good to be here.
So this concludes our experts in
emotion interview with Doctor Barbara
Fredrickson from the University
of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
Thank you again, Barbara. Okay, so.